[Musique]
le quartier chinois de montréal est en
proie à l'embourgeoisement depuis
plusieurs années ce qui représente une
sérieuse menace à son patrimoine c'est
un quartier qui subit beaucoup beaucoup
de pression immobilière donc on sentait
vraiment l'urgence d'agir
c'est pourquoi québec intervient pour
protéger le quartier chinois le coeur du
chinatown est en voie d'être classés
comme site patrimonial dont deux
bâtiments l'édifice de la british and
kelly jones coup reconnue comme étant la
maison wings et l'ancienne manufacture
est d'avis henson de la protection
extérieure de ses bâtiments protégera
notre patrimoine permettra à la
communauté le faire vivre ces lieux
emblématiques et avec ses légumes et sa
médecine traditionnelle le quartier est
plus qu'une accumulation de commerce
c'est l'âme d'une communauté une
histoire de l'immigration un pou depuis
plus de 120 ans ont dit oui à ce qui
avait été cassée chappuis qui tiennent à
son à cette identité là et qui étaient
ou pas mais certains s'inquiètent quand
même la portion préserver ne touche que
le coeur du quartier c'est pourquoi la
ville de montréal a adopté une
résolution pour limiter immédiatement
les auteurs et la densité permise dans
ce secteur pour s'assurer que le
développement immobilier se fasse de
façon
harmonieuse et parce que c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour vos premiers pas pour
pouvoir préserver le large quartier
chinois comme la plupart des membres de
sa communauté il se réjouit mais demeure
sur ses gardes où on espère que ce n'est
pas un business il annonce que
l'extérieur ces chinois mais l'intérieur
qu'ils me donnent à la starbox donc
c'est l'important c'est vraiment de
préserver larmes quatre chinois il ne
faut pas que le conte conserve seulement
que les façades pourquoi parce que ce
patrimoine l'eau dans le quartier
chinois il est toujours vivant la ville
de montréal soutient que ce n'est qu'un
premier geste pour préserver et
revitaliser le quartier chinois ici
marie josée paquet comme radio canada
montréal